welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and xq x-men united joined the
warring sides of mutankind
to fight the real enemy us well not just
us
us murica with an ever expanding cast of
mutants that wolverine tells to go [ __ ]
themselves
but in the munich circus i was known as
the incredible night caller [ __ ]
yourself
after breaking down the first x-men let
us now re-examine the sequel for all the
interesting easter eggs you might
overlook
because folks both deadpool and a couple
of avengers
make cameos here but there's also a ton
of easy to miss filmmaking details that
are just
really fun to talk about okay after
again opening with the x of the fox logo
lingering a bit longer
we open in outer space with a humanoid
shape and a fiery inner
glow the phoenix force making her way to
jean grey
charles is talking about mutants
replacing humanity though he doesn't
realize an even more evolved omega level
higher form
is approaching to replace even him a
white house tour guide quotes
lincoln from the break of america's last
civil war right before another one's
about to begin
we are not enemies but friends though
passion may have strained
it must not break the bonds of our
affection this guide is actually a cameo
by jubilee voice actor from x-men
evolution chiara zanny
lincoln like the portrait nightcrawler
mirrors jfk
both these presidents infamously were
assassinated just a little dark american
history to start the tension here
this amazing opening attack is senator
kelly's worst case scenario
a girl in illinois who can walk through
walls
now what's to stop her from walking into
the white house but unlike the iconic
white house attack from superman 2
the point of view here has been reversed
from the attackers
to the victims the first x-men was
almost exclusively through the eyes of
the mutants from the outside looking in
but x2 shifts the point of view to that
of the humans on the inside
who now look helpless and terrified from
charles's opening words this film is all
about
fear mutants since the discovery of
their existence they have been regarded
with fear
suspicion often hatred fear of the
other the direction here empathizes with
the humans as
victims notice how we stay mostly inside
the oval office
while everything goes down outside of it
bewildered secret service agents
bickering over how many assassins there
are
it's not clear we don't know how many
there are forced only to listen as the
calamity goes down right
outside which we know where it is thanks
to a clever shot through the peephole
to establish the geography
yeah this silence is scary it's like a
horror film with survivors holed up
against an
unknown terror now the brief glimpses we
do get a nightcrawler he
is creeping behind a door like he's
insidious
or crouched up in the ceiling corner
like yeah like
insidious which i know came out years
after but it just goes to show how james
wan watched this and was like
holy [ __ ] i'm using that even the choral
music here
is dias irae from mozart's requiem a
funeral composition
originally a gregorian chant whose theme
has been worked in as the theme of doom
everywhere from horror movies like the
shining to dark moments of star wars to
even
the mcu
and then finally the door swings open
showing only this blue
smoke the aftermath of dozens of
teleportations by nightcrawler
really his smoking gun and i love the
smoke design
ribbony wisps that snake in and out of
space
you know as opposed to like magic show
puffs or like portals by depicting
teleportation this way
bamf you can kind of sense kurt like
reaching and bending his
limbs and his tail into these various
spatial access points
it's great how they show us multiple
teleports within a single cut
glorifying it it is sexy ingenious
casting of alan [ __ ] fluent german
speaker
and vilco means stage performer from
cabaret
then nightcrawler gets shot in the arm
and notice how he lets out this canine
yelp
interesting because in the next scene
logan is also framed with canine imagery
the wolf he follows and another wolf
that he cross dissolves into into the
museum
reflecting mutants as both the wild
wolves that humans would hunt
and wolves that would hunt them but now
they're the evolved species that is
replacing humans one of those hunted
mutants from the previous film gets
respects paid here
sabretooth and there's a little mutant
skirmish on a smaller scale
artie not here yeah a little set up for
a much better time and place for artie
to pull his big move
wonder someone will finish what i've
started wolverine
one day jean grey's telepathy overwhelms
her
cancer all right they're gonna kill him
i love that kid hi there's a very cool
detail
three of those voices you just heard
were audio clips from
other parts of the movie so the shelter
was a secret service agent from the
opening scene
there's something in the corner no was
logan's voice
later in the movie
and they're gonna kill him was rogue's
voice
the phoenix force is allowing gene to
hear voices from the future
suggesting phoenix isn't bound by time
and that as we'll see in days of future
past consciousness-based time travel
is possible in this universe scott
confirms that gene's subtle reaction to
magneto's mutant conversion device in
the previous film is what awoke this
force inside her ever since liberty
island
even different a deleted scene would
have shown the recast jubilee sparking
up her fingers
she does show up in the final scene with
charles instead we just see the recast
pyro torching dudes bringing charles to
do his favorite move
free everybody pokeman
but this breeze is my favorite because
it causes these humans
to freeze like the early human exhibit
mannequins that
evolved mutants equate them to logan roy
himself plays colonel striker adapted
from reverend striker
in the god loves man kill story that
this adapted from but instead of an
anti-mutant pastor this striker is kind
of a bush-era hawk
using fear of the other to detain and
torture he's accompanied by eureka oyama
lady deathstrike
notice how he waves off the day drink
because as we'll learn later his son
jason would trap him in illusions and
he's probably now terrified of his mind
ever being in
any kind of intoxicated or vulnerable
state and brian cox rips senator kelly
mystique in disguise
i was piloting black ops missions in the
jungles of north vietnam where you were
sucking on your mama's tedded woodstock
kelly
now later in the series or earlier
chronologically the alternate timeline
versions of mystique and striker do run
into each other and fight
in vietnam eric reads t.h white's the
once and future king
the story of king arthur extending the
chess motif as this toppled king plots
his comeback at the end of the film
charles calls it back
have any of you read a book by an
english novelist
named t.h white but interestingly the
characters seen
sitting across the chessboard from
charles in this movie
is gene an example of her rise in power
and intellect the next evolutionary
threat to charles and eric's rule
charles shows logan cerebro continue
smoking that in here and you'll spend
the rest of your days under the belief
that you're a six-year-old girl
the illusion of a young girl is exactly
what jason striker uses to trick charles
in the rebuilt cerebro
but before i continue this video is
brought to you by audible in their
unmatched selection of audiobooks and
other audio products
with so many of us stuck at home with
libraries and schools closed
audible has stepped up to help they
launched
stories.audible.com for kids and parents
stuck at home to stream
great stories for free they got c.s
lewis scarlett johansson reading alice
in wonderland
and a whole bunch more family-friendly
stuff for free during quarantine
stories.audible.com they also launched
audible sleep
a free service with all kinds of bedtime
stories guided meditations
and other ways that we can wrestle a
good night of shut-eye back from the
stress monsters invading all of our
homes right now
they've even expanded the amount of
content available to existing members
that content includes the
best selection of audiobooks podcasts
and audible originals you can't find
anywhere else their audiobook selection
includes my old favorite
michael crichton's jurassic park i tear
through that book like a hungry
velociraptor oh
cool but you know one who eats great
novels instead of hunters
or finally get into that game of thrones
stephen king or neil gaiman audiobook
you've been thinking about
start listening with a 30-day audible
trial choose one audiobook and two
audible originals
absolutely free visit audible.com new
rockstars or text
new rockstars 2 500 500 again that's
audible.comrockstars or text new
rockstars to 500
500 for one audiobook and two audible
originals absolutely free mystique
accesses stryker's computer and the
names of pretty much every x-men
character or thing
show up on it first on the drop down
menu we'll go through these quick john
allardyce pyro
amara aquila magma allison blair dazzler
valley of levin skidz
braddock psylocke maria calistanos
ferrell cassidy 2 refers to
sean cassidy banshee and theresa cassidy
siren we see in this movie lila chaney
is an associate of the x-men in the new
mutants
victor creed saber-tooth he did roberto
de costa sunspots coming to new mutants
dane polaris bobby drake iceman in this
movie fred duke's blob
angelo espinosa skin kyle gibney wild
child
guthrie 2 refers to paige husk and sam
guthrie cannonball who's also coming in
the new mutants kanucho harada silver
samurai garrison kane weapon x from
x-force
remember gambit eric lyncher magneto
artie maddox is that fork tongued kid
jamie madrox is multiple man
giancoymon is karma and of course
maximoff 2 refers to the mutants
wanda maximoff scarlet witch pietro max
moth quicksilver
with versions that also showed up in the
mcu kevin mctaggart probably refers to
proteus a little bit differently but
yeah the son of morrow mctaggart and
danielle moonstar mirage also shown up a
new mutants and of course aurora monroe
storm now the designers also snuck in
the crew's faces on the guard ids tom
desanto is the executive producer
michael doherty and dan harris are
co-writers
l donner probably refers to lauren
schuller donner the co-producer
and yeah the director brian singer who
also shows up wheeling charleston to
visit eric but there's more easter eggs
here
because all the other desktop folders
reference the rest of the x-men universe
the drop-down menu reference most of
them here the rest omega red is an x-men
villain franklin richards is the son of
reed richards and sue storm super
powerful omega level mutants project
white awake is part of the sentinel
creation
mirror island is the mutant research
center created by mauro mctaggart rose
byrne in first class and it showed up in
the last standpost credits scene when
charles reincarnates kinda is that what
he did root bat sarah is sabra
cecilia reyes also appearing in new
mutants everett thomas cinch
nicole and claudette st kroy our psychic
twin mutants kurtz wagner nightcrawler
raven darkhome that's mystique vanessa
carlile copycat and then
here he is wade wilson deadpool just
waiting to make a really disappointing
appearance in x-men origins wolverine
then of course scott summers cyclops
doug ramsey cipher
andrea and andreas von strucker those
are the twins from the gifted who become
fenris black tom cassidy kind of makes a
cameo deadpool 2.
david north aka maverick in agent zero
tabitha smith is boom boom calvin rankin
is mimik
and then dr nathaniel essex aka mr
sinister or sinister who was
set up in the apocalypse post-credits
scene never went anywhere with that
mortimer twin b
it's toad he did ileana rasputin magic
also coming to new mutants shiro yoshida
sunfire guido carusella strong guy
catherine kitty pride shadowcat
obviously
dr carl lycos sauron now massachusetts
academy refers to the new site of
savior's school in the comics
trask is bolivar trask creator of the
sentinels appeared in days of future
past grey malkin is a mutant who gets
his powers from the dark
and zero tolerance refers to a comic
storyline where they were hunting down
mutants
and then there's alpha flight beta
flight and gamma flight those are all
canadian mutant teams department h
another file is the organization that
oversees them jamie braddock is
psylocke's older brother who can
manipulate reality danger room you know
this one this is the x-men simulation
training chamber
forge is a tech savvy weapons expert in
the x-men comics brotherhood is
magneto's crew weapon x so striker's
operation
legacy was a virus released by strife
against
mutants in the comics and then the
morlocks those are the underground
mutant group
okay outside the church where storm and
gene find kurt is graffiti reading that
nature laughs last kind of a reflection
how despite humans efforts to stamp out
mutants natural selection
finds a way kurt snaps at them in german
yeah his german translates to get out
i'm a minion of the devil
i am the spawn of evil striker's unit
attacks the school at nighttime another
amazing sequence that heightens
fear of the other after empathetically
relating to the fear of the humans in
the opening now
we are afraid of how that fear turned
state forces into night monsters
terrifying kids wolverines berserk in
the best possible way
let's go we see kitty pride in action
shifting through her bed and the walls
siren wakes up sounds the alarm colossus
meddles up wrecks some dudes
bobby forms an ice wall between logan
and stryker like in the opening scene
logan is iced out of his past
meanwhile mystique seduces the guard on
the tv
is a sighting of dr hank mccoy beast
before he was recast as kelsey grammer
in the last stand
also on that talk show is mr shaw
referring to sebastian shaw
leader of the hellfire club kevin bacon
played him first class now notice how
the bathroom is pretty big for a bar
that's because this set was actually
built for the first film when they were
gonna do a flashback to scott summer's
origin destroying his high school
bathroom
that scene was later re-shot for x-men
apocalypse now stryker is exploiting his
son
jason striker a telepathic mutant that
charles could not help so he would tour
with our minds
projecting visions and scenarios into
our brains
my wife she took a power drill to her
left temple
in an attempt to bore the images out
jason is based on jason wingard aka the
mutant mastermind with similar powers
bobby's family cat licks logan's claws
actually listen when he retracts them
yeah it's a subtle off-screen
disappointing from the kitty now bobby
comes out as a mutant to his parents a
metaphor for gay teens coming out
that idea of homophobia versus pride
runs throughout these films
it's just that it's not easy when you
want to be closer to someone
but you can't when did you first know
you were
a mutant have you tried
not being a mutant then why not stay in
disguise all the time
because we shouldn't have to in 2015
marvel comics established bobby drake as
gay
magneto's prison escape is set to mozart
and he sucks the metal from the blood
notice how he's smiling gleefully as he
floats on that disc bullets those balls
in the guard booth this contrast of
classical music and
horrible gore was inspired directly from
hannibal lecter's escape in silence of
the lambs
the pilot ordering them to land as
captain raygun mccly
not to captain raymond raygun lie in
battlestar galactica nightcrawler
teleports rogue back into a crashing jet
but
luckily magneto catches them when will
these people learn how to fly
yeah kind of a meta joke about how in
the comics and in the animated series
rogue jean grey they fly all the time
so does storm but in this movie it's
only really storm she only really flies
when like the storm wins to levitate her
now they end up using mystique to pose
as wolverine but stryker ain't fooled
the one thing i know better than anyone
is my own work seal the room
shoot it i love this striker can tell
just by mystique's calm confidence
that this ain't the same unsettled lab
break that he saw in the mansion earlier
and as a past victim of his son's
illusion stryker is just really sharp
when it comes to knowing what's the real
thing
mystique flips him off with a backward
slide a move she learned from logan in
the first film and she morphs so fast
that even we're surprised
could be anybody
[Music]
brian cox did all that i love it and
then mystique slips in some sass
can you shut it down from here no come
this little time
not without us gene's telepathy is
leading her to suspect eric and mystique
have ulterior plans for cerebral
as they do and when they save the mutant
captives notice how the before angle
shows kurt
already standing in the shadows of that
containment cell before
his character teleports in clearly they
planned to digitally remove him from the
shot but maybe they didn't think he
would be visible but he is
logan discovers his old weapon x lab
where he was experimented on with x-ray
scans showing
other past test subjects mutants we know
the skull with the spikes belongs to
quill who arrives in the next film you
can also see the hand of lady
deathstrike but there's also this
wing that belongs to angel whose feather
wings are replaced by metallic ones
wolverine and lady deathstrike had this
nasty fight until he plugs her with
molten adamantium and sadly
notice how stryker's brainwashed serum
fades from her eyes at the last
second and briefly you can see this
lucid regret as she looks at logan
as adamantium pours out like tears it's
tragic but it reminds logan that the
real enemy not his fellow mutants
but us u.s mercy
striker and jason used charles and
cerebral to target all the mutants now
deleted scenes here would have shown
this movie's hank coy and agony
transforming into his beast form
as well as gambit playing cards with his
energy flaring up suddenly sadly we
never got to see those
but then magneto and mystique try to
reverse it on the humans but storm and
nightcrawler break charles free but
notice how they leave poor jason behind
like eureka another exploited mutant
casualty
but the dam breaks and jean knows it was
her powers that damaged it before
and that she's the only one who could
save them and the way charles has in the
past used his psionic powers to talk
through people
jean and now proves her alpha status by
doing it through
him this is the only way later in the
final shot charles will
sense jean's ongoing presence outside
the window and she
further takes away the alpha status by
quoting charles's opening words from the
first film
over the final shots of the phoenix
rising from under the water
but every few hundred millennia
evolution leaps forward but because this
battle was sparked by
fear of the other in order to extinguish
it they must return to where that first
blood was drawn
the oval office where charles echoes the
senator kelly kitty pride reference
that first fueled this anxiety just say
i know a little girl who can walk
through walls
the first film ended with a chess match
between mutants
now charles pivots and signals the game
is now between
humans and x-men united the next move is
yours
join our future weekly watch longs on
our official discord server by becoming
a patron at patreon.com new rockstars
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love and let us close
with what the rest of murica probably
saw when the president's live feed went
dead there
[Music]
so